the Amazon and MGM marketing team have
been asked to put together a report
about something very interesting
regarding Stargate welcome to Sidetrack
your Sci-Fi TV the movie channel
[Music]
so it seems to be now the worst kept
secret in Hollywood that Stargate is
going to be returning this has been
actually confirmed by a couple of
different sources now even though if
you're a regular site tracker you heard
it here first
but thanks to my sources close to MGM
I've been able to get some very very
interesting information that I'm going
to be sharing with you over the next few
days first of all this is something that
I actually dropped in a live video on
Wednesday night before we go into some
really exclusive stuff in the next
couple of videos
but that actually somebody that I know
very well has access to some of the
marketing and PR meetings
in those meetings last week these teams
are asked to put together a couple of
reports based on some development ideas
so now first of all the really big
interesting thing here is that it was
actually
um something called development reports
or development data they're trying to
put together now my sources told me this
is something they do very early on in
development when there's a couple of
different ideas knocking around they
want to gauge the public interest in a
couple of those different ideas now they
have done this previously and I've got a
nice thing a year ago now they put a
bunch of questionnaires out via Amazon
and part of those question is did ask
about Stargate they asked a lot of
questions about Stargate SGU they asked
a lot about what sort of project would
you want to see if Stargate were to be
revived would you want to see a movie
would you want to see a hard reboot a
hard reboot was actually talked about a
lot in that questionnaire when they're
trying to get that data hold on to that
thinking for a second and they actually
sent these questionnaires out to
thousands of Amazon customers what do
you remember about Stargate what did you
love about Stargate what didn't you like
about Stargate blah blah blah well this
development data is far more focused
there are actually only really four
questions on it and first of all I have
to say at no point do they mention a
hard reboot which is just Bliss because
after deadline very very recently
actually reported that yes there is
going to be a Stargate project and yes
it is probably going to be a movie lots
of people pick that up and I actually
saw a story a couple of days later from
screenland suggesting that Roland
Emerick was finally going to be allowed
to do his Trilogy of movies that would
have been a hard reboot I can actually
tell you that reading the story it just
sort of says that look they tried to do
that seven or eight years ago so why
wouldn't they do it now
because it's a completely different
situation and Ronald Emerick has already
pretty much said he doesn't want to do
it so we can eliminate the hard reboot
as a possibility I feel at this point
so what were the questions they
basically wanted to judge the fans
reaction to four different scenarios
them doing a TV series where at least
some of the regular original cast would
return
or do we do a new television series with
completely new cast perhaps with some
cameos from original cast members do we
do a movie with the original cast or do
we do a movie where it's all new cast
but possibly with some cameos and they
wanted to gauge the opinion from Gators
on all of those different scenarios
so I thought I'd do a little bit of
market research for them and ask the
question first I wanted to put this from
a slightly different angle because I've
actually asked you guys lots of times
over the last few months what would you
like to see when they revived the
Stargate so I took these four proposals
and I asked you guys what is the one you
like the least
so new series with some original cast 29
of the votes new series all new cast
maybe some cameos 23 percent of the
votes new movie with some original cast
six percent of the votes a new movie all
new cast maybe some cameos 42 of the
vote
so remembering that this is the project
you like the sound of the least
50 of the votes are actually more than
after a TV series that you actually like
that idea the least that you want a TV
series with either original cast or not
original cast that comes up to what just
over 50 percent of the vote so there's a
lot of you guys out there that aren't
particularly excited about a TV show
new movie with some of the original cast
six percent of the vote can I come back
to that in a second but the new movie
with all newcast maybe some cameos that
is the idea you like the least and to be
honest it's the scenario that I think is
probably most likely to actually happen
but 42 percent of you after 545 votes I
only put it on late last night
have said I do not want this project we
do not want a movie with all new cast we
hate that idea
but a new movie with a lot of the
original cast returning
now this is going to be with newcast as
well it just is they're going to want to
bring in some new blood into this it's
just that's just sensible but well
there's many of the new cast returning
in proper roles returning roles that's
the important thing here that is by far
the project that scares you guys the
least now I know from talking to you a
lot over the last 12 months most people
that have come on the channel and just
talked about this with me have actually
said they would love to see a TV series
it's less risky than a movie but that's
what they'd love to see when I actually
first suggested that this was going to
be a possibility late last year that it
looked like Amazon would seriously
consider in a movie
then actually to be honest the reaction
to that was oh God no why why would you
do that to us
but you guys seem to have come around to
that thinking and got used to the idea
of actually now it being a movie so a
big cinematic release with some of the
cast like Michael Shanks Amanda Tapping
Richard Dean Anderson returning
now that would be exciting and I have
some more information about that but
it's going to be in the next video but
guys I'd love to know exactly what you
think about this proposal there's four
of them which is the one you like most
but I'd love to know a little bit more
information about what you're thinking
if you're thinking that a movie actually
is the best way to go with this but you
must have some of those actors return
which ones would you pick now I know
this is a dream scenario where you'd
want everybody but you can't because you
know we're not going to spoil you like
that Amazon aren't going to be that
sweet
so who would you pick who were the
actors that are a must I'd love to know
what you think get into the comments if
you're new to the channel like subscribe
hit the Bell notification you know what
to do hit all those buttons but please
guys most importantly as always stay
safe and I'll see you next time
foreign
[Music]